israeli soldiers rammed through the
doors of darkened offices rifled through
documents and confiscated property in
ramallah
seven non-governmental organizations
were raided including those serving
palestinian women and children and
providing legal assistance on their way
out the soldiers sealed doors and
declared the offices closed employees
say these are humanitarian organizations
helping palestinians living under
israeli occupation we don't take our
legality
from the occupying power our legality is
coming from the nature of our work we
are working in law and also it comes
from our
people you know and it comes from the
victims the palestinian victims this is
you know our legitimacy the israeli
defense minister designated the
non-governmental institutions as
terrorist organizations israel says they
are tied to the popular front for the
liberation of palestine which it also
deems a terrorist organization
the government accuses these groups of
operating under false pretenses of
providing humanitarian assistance when
in fact they're helping recruit fighters
raising money and engaging in fraud the
palestinian prime minister says some of
the organizations targeted have been in
existence since before the arab israeli
war of 1967. donors will continue to
fund we will continue to help these
institutions as long as they are working
within the palestinian laws and they are
we have licensed them they submit
reports on annual basis the un condemned
the raids and called on israel to
immediately reverse its decision it's
unclear what long-term effect the raids
will have on the ability of these
organizations to operate
employees say the only thing illegal
here is the israeli raids they're
cleaning up and say they'll continue
their mission to serve the palestinian
people natasha ghanim al jazeera west
jerusalem